[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ça m a fait ça fait plaisir
elle va rester avec moi et ça qu on peut
pas donner à boire un peu une chamelle
là elles sont comme si elle était en
terrasse poney quelque chose merci est
ce que j'avais envie de boire mais chéri
bien aller pour donner là on va vous
donner quelque chose à boire tout va
bien se passer
ne vous inquiétez pas alors on a un
autre garçon qui est là si l'appel jean
victor louis jean victor est avec nous
il a 20 ans savage henvic france comment
on appelle tes potes le monde avait des
bonnes j'y vais j'y vais j'ai choisi
tu as 20 ans et moi j'adore tout nu déjà
sans rigoler non mais comment tu as eu
l'idée frérot de te dire je vais garder
un techo où je suis complètement rasé
ces gens on voit mais cjv mais dans ce
palais à ces cgv
j'ai retourné mais j'adore j'adore ça
rigolait non c'est mon style
mais j'aime bien même bien tu as raison
moi j'aime les gens qui ont du style et
au niveau de la barre on fait quoi on
reste comme ça non mais comme restant
laspalès d'accord avec ta raison moi
j'aime bien je trouve que ça te va très
très bien alors toi donc tu as 20 ans
teddy d'arrêter les études mais j'ai
raté là je vais travailler mois prochain
ça m'a l'air sous tous ses coups le gars
il m'a fait une réponse comme s'il
parlait à son père c'est ou pas non j'ai
arrêté par ramé mois prochain on fait ça
parce que j'ai le gars de l'université
normalement je peux faire un truc en
alternance n'essayez pas tout [ __ ] de
ma gueule en vacances 30 chez eux tandis
qu'antoine a coûté tranquille tu faisais
quoi tu es le bac un jeu le bakoye quel
bac commerce ses ventes progresser dans
plein cet été c'est quoi c'est quoi un
bac pro bac ce commerce mais j'ai fait
ça parce que c'est pas ta question envie
de faire moi ouais non non le gall moi
franchement j'aimerais bien travailler
dans le dos de visuels ou dans le
showbiz dans l'atelier la télé alors là
tout ce qui était lé show bis et bnl à
la 40 ans de métier je peux te dire non
mais c'est quoi que tu aimerais faire
quoi ce qu'il ya là plein ya plein de
jeunes qui je veux faire salve et à la
fin c'est genre plus je vais être connue
qu'est en quoi tu te sens bon voilà
qu'est ce qui est ce que tu m'as entre
opus mois déjà c'est quand j'étais petit
j'ai commencé à gagner tous les
émissions toutes les émissions tout
l'été les machins et c'est aussi
pourquoi pas moi parce que pour moi je
pense que je pense que luigi talent j'ai
du talent pour moi alors animateur c'est
ça animateur ou chroniqueurs ouais
j'aimerais bien c'est mon rêve
et alors qu'est quoi tu veux qu'on fasse
un truc est ce que tu peux essayer de
faire une entrée de l'émission fait le
début de l'émission tu présentes un peu
les gens je vois ce que tu veux qu'on
fasse ça ou pas ouais on enclenche un
jingle c'est parce attends attends je
vais me baril
j'ai envie de te dire j'y vais et là une
nouvelle revient quand des mois la cote
et match il ya côté d'm6 alors toi ans
plus tard capillairement déjà tu peux
amener un style c'est leur faut que toi
il faudrait que tu démarres comme ça à
mon avis tu es et tu fais une double
take tu vois comme ça tu vois tu vois
que comme ça tu fais comme ça ok je te
laisse givet tu fais une entrée
attention c'est parti c'est j'y vais j'y
vais tu es près d'eagle
c'est parti en vrille
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonsoir à tous bonsoir à tous et
jean-victor guyot donc voilà je vais
présenter mes chroniqueurs
bref vers apparu je vais présenter mes
condoléances au maroc on la refait tu
mets tu mais on y va bonsoir à tous t'as
pas besoin de te présenter une star donc
jean victor on le connaît tapé jean
victor comment en bio henriot non anglio
aux clients
cyril rahmouna ball pro series on la
refait là tu me mets du punch ok oui ce
monde y va on relance le jingle on y va
et là bon soir à tout salut merci d'être
avec nous dans touche pas à mon âge on
est si près midi après le message estime
t comme tu le sors d'accord j'aime bien
il ya la marche bien la maladie bébé
vas-y
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
tous n'ont pas volé
non pas pour aller alors c'est un grand
plaisir de reprendre les rênes de cette
émission voilà que ce chant très bon fan
de cinéma laisser la place donc voilà
c'est moi car au prix d'émission donc
baja km et indices et applaudissements
[Applaudissements]
il a le sourire il a quelque chose
franchement benhaim pour il ya quarante
ans de métier il y avait moi je vous le
jure extrêmement scientifique 40 ans
rapide me croyais qu'il y avait un
dossier sur son tabouret voilà on a
failli le perdre bêtement bêtement
pendant ces travaux secteur oui non mais
j'ai extrêmement surprise m'a toujours
de cette jeune génération qui est hyper
à l'aise en fait est le média télé ils
le connaissent il le voilà c'est ils
l'appréhendent y perd facilement ils
n'ont pas de trac sur ça est-ce que vous
voyez pour lui une carrière
en ce qui le concerne
professionnellement
oui des gens qui nous rejoignent toutes
les minutes
c'est la vraie personne non c'est pas
faux de ce qu'on a râlé genre un gars
qui se fait passer pour un yoga c'est la
vraie personne c'est une vraie personne
c'est un vrai gars voilà je voulais vous
dire c'est en voyant qui sera avec nous
et claude vous allez en faire beaucoup d
émission avec moi j'espère tout et on va
le voir près on dirait que le gall
[ __ ] pour le faire parler derrière
est ce que vous voyez une carrière pour
notre ami j'y vais il sera dans un
milieu artistique mais je le vois plus
en angleterre
franchement c'est une bonne nouvelle
s'est exporté à l'international en fait
ça ouais à ce que j'avais à faire des
cures là
[Rires]
laissons leur laissons le d'avoir perçu
en france après prendra le k800 il part
en tout cas à la fois je vois également
faire des castings ou à vous déplacer je
vous allez courir les castings vous
quelque chose vous allez vous présenter
mes cibles pour participer peut-être une
télé réalité
ah ouais ça vous dirait ça fera alors
franchement là le 20 ans il ya deux
trois ans j'étais très intéressé pour
faire ce genre d'émission mais
maintenant ça me plaît ça ne plaît pas
énormément fois c'est ça c'est je
regarde comme tout derrière sur le long
terme voilà long terme et à quelque
chose au sérieux en fait t'as raison
voilà c'est son bébé et moi en tout cas
je te dis si je peux donner un coup de
main si j'ai des castings des trucs et
bah je le ferais on t'appellera s'il ya
des cas très gentil
juste ça chez lui en fait ils venaient
pas du tout pour ça à la base ils
venaient parce qu'en fait tu
collectionnes les photos avec des stars
combien de photos une centaine centaine
avec qui c'est qui les plus grosses
stars dennis ouest kanye west d'accord
il est ouest elie semoun
[Rires]
voilà ça c'est moi dans 20 ans
sinon c'est moi kanye west et toi non
mais je suis c'est super tie bokura
frère en redingote aime beaucoup
huawei et vous aussi
on va au restaurant d'un restaurant
ouais mais bon c'était vers l'avenue
vers la butte montana l'avenue c'est
vrai parions que je suis du bon c'est
pas mal
kad merad je connais les gars joris hugo
lloris très sympa à hugo lloris très
bien ben on est en l1 et a des stats
acquis comme star internationale a par
kanye west
non franchement je suis d'accord mais
qu'est ce qu'il fait là
non non non ça s'est mal passé mais
pourquoi ou à très très mal passé ce qui
s'est passé à christina normalement
c'est un amour puis je les ai vus la
semaine dernière raconte donc je vois là
d'être en chine etc
et puis je la vois et puis moi bah voila
je fais à ma chérie comme faits relatés
ma chérie fm dit c'est pas mon chéri ton
nom n'était pas mon chéri déjà un truc
et puis le volley peut-être non non il
volait bas paris voulait vraiment pas
qui est ce que tu as eu déjà des gens de
désagréable j'étais sympa moi comptes a
demandé une photo avec moi franchement
tu peux dire que c'est encore loin dans
le restaurant et moi j'ai voulu prendre
une table pour manger à côté mais toutes
été réservées en fait savoir jeudi
qu'ils aient qui est ce qu a eu déjà des
gens très désagréable c'était kg pire
sur le guerchin qui leur fut un joker la
guerre car lagerfeld - ouais ouais ouais
de rencontres eu franchement il m'a dit
ah ouais ouais mais bref parce que lui
déjà capillairement déjà et a dû avoir
du mal
je connais déjà il a dû se dire le gars
est chelou déjà moi j'ai un catogan le
gard un catogan ici ça fait beaucoup de
catogan et le plus sympa moi je pensais
même pas j'ai beaucoup sympathise avec
les joueurs du psg aussi les gens du psg
sont très sympas les joueurs du
président avait juste qu'ils me
reconnaissent non ou pas des masses à
ces abris et ça c'est bien ça c'est
benhaim avant le prochain marc augé
radio à très bien mais en tout cas merci
d'être là moshiri problème vous le savez
on va continuer encore doux témoignage à
faire après ils en pensent quoi camille
vous savez que j'ai perdu une dent si
vous nous rejoignez maintenant j'ai
perdu une dent tout à l'heure dans cette
émission un morceau dont je crois que le
dentiste est arrivé je sais pas ce qu'il
va pouvoir faire alors qu allez-vous
quoique le col et vous croyez quoi qu'il
aurait d'après ce qu'on peut avoir un
témoignage et un diagnostic du dentiste
mais merci
à l'est des landes
[Applaudissements]
on sent alors c'est la lentille malades
amsellem comment ça va mais dites moi eh
ouais ouais ouais elle est pas mal
attentifs pendant des mois on voit
d'habitude ne fait pas la bise à son
dentiste
on se connaît elle est jalouse
ah oui il n'ya pas de céder dans ce
n'est pas ne pas toucher rectal
non mais alors non pas la même chaîne m
pour les gens qui nous regardent ce que
ça peut arriver de perdre une dent au
travail sur un chantier ou bien entendu
en cours de mathématiques
donc est-ce que c'est pose qu'est-ce
qu'on va faire là c'est pas marqué alors
regardez ma dent d'accord si vous voulez
regarder tout ça moi je continue des
missions et des cousins diagnostic on
sent pas penser qu'on peut faire quelque
chose
1 on peut recoller quelque chose
d'accord alors vous avez raison je
rappelle que donc nous c'est une
dentiste qui est très forts que nous eh
oui ni non on ne répond pas toi vous
êtes très très belle vous êtes kessoua
et faire la daille creuser elle n'est
pas venue de l'année toi je vais laisser
les russes et moi je verrais alors les
chéris j'aimerais qu'on s'intéresse deux
petites secondes à notre ami qui est
avec nous qui est en bout de table mais
juste avant on va parler d'eux les
vannes les vannes à merci d'être avec
nous ma chérie tu à 11 ans bonjour les
bana
et toi et toi tu as une vie
exceptionnelle tard en tentant quelle
classe je suis vient de rentrer en
sixième tu vas dans troisième n'a jamais
redoublé tu travailles bien tu avais
cours aujourd'hui ou pas oui j'avais
qu'on met pas manquer pour moi oui et
donc tu avais tu avec toi quand même
matière aujourd'hui je connais pas mon
emploi du temps partie quand même cet
après-midi normalement je vais français
et éducation musicale accorde à
l'éducation musicale rsa c'est important
pour toi ouais bachiri alors ta 11 ans
était venu avec ta maman bien entendu et
toi tu as une vie extraordinaire parce
qu'on compte à vue dans nombreux films
et tu joues dans une série que j'adore
c'est nos chers voisins
regardez il ya donc plus y forcer la
main aux deux de sherbrooke alors est-ce
que déjà c'est difficile de jouer plein
d'adultes ou bien est ce que tu es un
petit peu la star s qui sont hyper sympa
avec toi ils sont tout le temps derrière
toi bah en fait c'est un peu la chouchou
on va dire ça
ouais bah ils sont hyper sympa vraiment
j'adore cette ambiance c'est génial
série cote alors est-ce que mine de rien
quand tu retournes à l'école après
quelle est la réaction des copains parce
que quand ils voient ce qu'ils voient
comme une star à l'école qu'un acquis de
vannes un peu sk qui nous est pas
empêché star est ce qu'ils sont jaloux
ce qu'il ya des jalousies
il ya des jalousies mais il ya beaucoup
qui me dit
hand à vue hier avec le poisson qui est
mort c'est l'épisode qui revient très
souvent le poison est est ce que t es ce
que tu as été prof est ce qui est ce qui
te connaissent ce qu'ils savent côté que
tu es une grande comédienne soit on ne
voit pratiquement tous les soirs sur tf1
ou pas du tout bal avec la rentrée au
collège bas du côté des nouveaux profs
dont ils ne savent pas y en a peut-être
encore deux mois mais y en a qui
connaissent mon frère ces comédiens un
petit peu et donc ils disent ah tu étais
là sur des toits adacore madrid mais
chez nous tout est regarde pas enfin
peut-être
c'est pas dur de reprendre les cours
quand on est on est voilà quand on est
comme ça on veut qu'on joue la comédie
est aussi chanteuse 1 voilà parce que tu
as fais overy skid d'ailleurs je te
rappelle louis tu avais été tu avais été
dans the voice kid et j'étais hyper
énervé que tu sois pas sélectionné ce
truc là et vu cet extrait on l'a où on
l'a on l'a où on l'a pas l'extrait on
n'a pas qu'on l'a pas ouais c'est un
extrait de notre propre émission mais on
ne l'a pas c'est pour ça qu'on aime on
aime on aime cette équipe et ils vont
avoir exactement cinq minutes pour
trouver l'extrait on va voir comment va
se régler là dedans ma chérie tu restes
avec nous vous allez savoir dans un
instant jean claude jean claude qu'est
ce qu'il a à jean-claude 1
parce que jean-claude il a une
particularité il est beau il a 66 ans
joue le dit benhaim et pourrait
remplacer patoche celui ci dans un
instant il ya aussi les aventures de
camille et baba puisqu'il y aura un
camille et baba spéciales et vous vous
restez avec nous ça va le clôturer
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et je lui 35 heures de direct est ce
qu'on vous propose un jeu essayez donc
de battre ce record voilà de l'émission
voilà la plus longue en fait de la plus
le plus long passage à l'antenne
puisqu'il y aura tout à l'heure camille
et baba je vais enchaîner directement
sera aux alentours de 17 heures 10 si je
vous le dis ensuite touche pas à mon
poste ensuite c'est pour nous c'est
cadeau ensuite des défis avec des
chroniqueurs vous verrez ils vont
essayer de battre des records avec des
vrais recorman et puis la nuit vous
pouvez m'appeler je serai avec jean
michel mr et caroline ithurbide pour
recevoir vos appels ici même sur sur ce
plateau vous verrez on aura plein
d'appels on aura des happenings on aura
des actions vérité ça va être chaud
chaud chaud
je crois que c'est mon émission
l'émission que je quitte le plus demain
matin donc je serai je ferai la matinale
radio avec camille combal ici en direct
sur ces huit de 6h à 10h 10 heures
ensuite égérie on aura une autre
émission avec plein de chroniqueurs
voilà on fera la cuisine on fera le
jardinage durable au mof
voilà je vous dis aussi pour les
amateurs et ensuite bien sûr on fera
geoffrey l'édition spéciale j'ai dit je
vais remplacer daphné bürki l'édition
spéciale ça ça va être un exercice
difficile et ensuite touche pas mon
après on se retrouve avec d'autres
témoins demain après-midi et puis après
voilà voilà ccag libre ou terminera 2
heures du matin deux membres je sais pas
si je vais te dire mais ça s'annonce
bien
regardez ledentu fait partie il va
recoller la dent pour l'instant ça tient
je vous le dis donc on a deux défis
tenir 35 heures et garder sa dent pour
le moment il y à d'autres témoins donc
ils sont avec nous il y à jean-claude
inca 66 ans s'intéressera à lui dans un
instant il ya michel on a dû tout à
l'heure il est champion de ping pong à
89 ans il ya j'y vais j'y vais je
devenir une star et on va sauver lui on
va essayer de faire faire passer des
castings en tout cas des tyrans un
casting on lui dira ne change rien pour
l'instant tu tiens le bon bout je te le
dire en tout cas tu as quelque chose tu
as quelque chose on te retiens ça c'est
sûr on te retiens tu es comme williams
williams on le voit une fois on le
retient valérie bénaïm on la voit une
fois on la voit là les vannes à est avec
nous et on va parler de nicolas dans un
instant nicolas qui a 16 ans et lui
aussi qui vit un rêve il et maniéré
comme il est mignon nicolas savamment
nico mais content de te vois c'est un
plaisir s est une star nicosia qui fait
c'est vraiment une star elle evans a
aussi alors les vannes à ma chérie je
sais que tu étais dans the voice qui tu
n'as tu n'as pas idée pays je me
rappelle moi j'avais gueuler et où david
et moi je me serais retourné j'ai kiffé
et plus tard tu veux faire quoi tu veux
faire chanteuse ou pas chanteuse et
actrice chanteuse et actrice donc ce que
tu fais maintenant mais un peu plus tard
mais tu as tu veux continuer les cours à
te dis quoi ta maman elle te dis qu'il
faut que tu continues les cours il faut
que tu fasses mois ben elle voudrait me
faire prendre des cours par
correspondance
ouais et moi je dis au moins une année
de collège après pas c'est tout tu
pourras ah ouais donc là tu voudrais
faire la tasse 5e et après tu prends des
cours par correspondance et une relance
à fond dans la musique et dans la dans
la comédie assez ça alors il paraît que
ta ta ta un rêve par le témoignage est
une chanson que j'adore c'est libérer
des livres et de la reine des neiges
j'adore il paraît que tu adores anaïs
delva celle qui chante paraît que c'est
une idole absolue pareil tu rêve de
chanter avec elle alors qu est-ce que
vous qui êtes voyons est ce qu'à votre
avis un jour non mais c'est vrai ce cas
elle arrivera un jour à santé avec anaïs
delva c'est son rêve absolu c'est celle
qui chante la reine des neiges voulait
que vous rappelle l'arrêt dé la libérer
là je ne mentirai plus jamais je suis
sûr que vous allez réaliser son rêve
parce qu'elle va chanter avec elle très
prochainement donc c'est là dans les
prochaines minutes là là là ça passe par
mois ouais s'il pouvait vite tous éviter
de passer par mois en juin donc vous
pensez qu anaïs delva jla evans est ce
que tu l'as déjà rencontre anaïs delva
jamais et aimerait la rencontrer ou pas
là on n'a pas pu la faire venir
non mais c'est parce qu'elle est sûre
avec la reine des neiges dans le pré par
lé sur chamonix mais mais c'est vraiment
ton rêve de la rencontre et tu aimerais
chante avec elle libérée des livres et
vous n'avez pas rendu pas oui alors moi
ce que je propose c'est que tu commence
à chanter
est ce que tu peux nous chanter libéré
délivré avec moi prendre micro j'adore
cette chanson
ça commence comme ça l'hiver s'installe
doucement dans la nuit la neige et
rennes à son tour un voyage de seul hit
maker
[Musique]
je
les berrebi livrés
décidé je m'en vais vers s'installe au
centre nuit la nage irène à son tour
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
le
[Musique]
pense plus à demain au guichet est bien
trop fort j'ai lutté en vain que celle
du pouvoir n'ont pas bleue a fait
attention le secret sur ira
et m
[Musique]
de tournon
deux ans
m
lee
non
[Musique]
et plus jamais
je vois
[Musique]
richard
[Applaudissements]
vivez
[Musique]
le prix de la
monde de merde
autant pas
bros
et anaïs qui sera en tournée en france
en avril 2010 7 mars avril mai 2007
michèle savannah tu es content tant
chéri j'ai fait une belle surprise ou
pas c'est vrai qu'on a mais je suis
hyper heureux je te faire un petit gros
bisous un petit gros bisous elle est
belle et naturelle aussi très beau site
à un boulot si tu peux la garder les
vannes à tu pars tu pars à canaliser
toutes les deux je vous offre un séjour
à la neige
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
mais bon tu n'as pas ma part avec qui
elle sortait ensemble bondé
j'adore ça mais je kiffe cette émission
je sais pas pour vous donner ça fait
comme maintenant on va on va vraiment
avoir fait trois heures d'émission déjà
quatre futures à 3000 euros pour
l'association c'est que du bonheur les
shérifs les vannes 1 je suis content à
l'aller partie contente je commence il
ya des gens contents il ya des gens
contents dans un instant ça on
s'intéressera jean cot ça fait deux
heures que dick dans un important
attentat
jean-claude il a 66 ans le moment on va
s'intéresser à lui avant d'avoir 80
c'est un truc de fou quoi cette histoire
pour le moment c'est nicolas nicolas
mottet nicolas merci d'être là regardez
comme il est mignon lieu 600 écoles et
regardez moi ce beau gosse atteignent 9
bat non pas quel âge 16 ans n'a pas de
meuf est peut-être déjà sorti que neuf
avec la langue et où abbas a à base de
délire de galoches à amiens le maire qui
avait hier à catamarca regarde mais ta
mère alors les bombes a demandé qu elle
s'appelle madame mottet ouais et va
madame mottet été mis à terre les deux
minutes on doit parler au petit non sans
y est tu dois avoir une cote à l'école
lui c'est pile le gars de toutes les
meufs kif à l'école sympathie il est
souriant beaucoup comme ça qui part
comme ça
genre la pop ou déjà c'est une réussite
sur ma vie c'est vrai c'est que tu dois
tu as du succès à l'école balla en ce
moment en fait je suis je suis par
correspondance du coup c'est sûr qu'à la
maison il ya moins de passage
c'est sûr c'est sûr c'est ça il faut la
voir que tu as donc saison et toi aussi
tu as une histoire tu vis des aventures
extraordinaires parce que tu as suivi
une formation complète en chant en danse
en théâtre et à déjà 8 ans d'expérience
de scène tu as fait des comédies
musicales t'as fait quoi
j'avais fait on parlait de davos qui
j'ai fait la première saison de vote ce
qui devait arriver
la finale way et j'étais avec lui
bertignac ah ouais ouais c'est toi qui
l'avais choisi où il est c'est lui qui
table et à celui qui s'est retournée à
liessies avec lui ouais n'a cessé avec
louis bertignac n'aurait jamais non mais
je l'adoré jai la plus moi c'était mon
piano c'est un de mes préférés
c'est un très grand joueur de ping pong
louis ix est louis tu as dû te régaler
avec l'ugtt a donné plein de conseils
génial non la vente a encore des
contacts avec lui ouais il m'a posé son
e-mail c'était super sympa et puis du
groupe a conçu un jour de plus il répond
tout de suite c'est un amour de m et je
te dis propose de faire une d'un taux
rating pour mieux jouer et ils adorent
ça alors là en ce moment donc là tu vas
être le rôle principal de la comédie
musicale du événement oliver twist
alors on va rappeler les l'idée de
l'histoire de leader twist valérie
benaïm oliver tout est sa bête tu vas
peut-être mieux la raconter ça ça veut
dire qu'à la connais pas alors à côte
nous bat pour faire court en gros c'est
l'histoire d'un orphelin à londres et
qui part qui abandonnent leur fait l'ena
qui par la recherche de ses origines de
son père et sa voix ce que va y avait
des mecs croyais qu oliver twist un gars
qui s'appelle olivier qui dansait le
twitter et tous ont quitté sais pas
alors ta ta ta combien d'heures de
répétitions par jour alors les répète il
y avait pendant presque deux mois
c'était des journées complètes de répèt
du entre vite à 10h02 répète par jour
donc c'était vraiment intense et là du
coup on est en représentation du
vendredi au dimanche
donc là c'est la journée complète alors
moi moi c'est une question de poser
parce que c'est vrai qu'on se pose tous
la question pour pour nos enfants ici
mine de rien quand on a un enfant qu'à
16 ans qui va faire un gros rôle comme
ça
l'école est ce que c'est mort
franchement on se dit ça va être
compliqué après pour reprendre l'école
toi tu as envie de faire quoi plus tard
bien faire ça va nettement fait
j'aimerais continuer à faire ça mais je
me dis qu'il faut quand même passer le
bac donc je compte donc cela je passe le
bac
et puis après je reste ouvert à ce qui
se passe dans la suite tant qu'elle
classe 1re première première fois s
aulas en plus ça ouais c'est une des
plus dures à la première essayée maths
physique biologie tout ce qui concerne
la science et la technique de la voilà
non mais c'est vrai ça rigolait vous
valérie benaïm est-ce que vous assuriez
votre fils voilà partir sur une carrière
comme ça ou pas je suis pas certaine
centro question après 6,6 jeu le rend
malheureux alors en lui refusant
évidemment que je vais
et y réfléchir à deux fois et essayer de
trouver des solutions comme des horaires
aménagés où effectivement l'école à la
maison voilà il faut essayer de
dialoguer avec son ado pour voir canal
guy quoi ta maman maman du coup elle l a
toujours fait en sorte que tout se passe
bien enfin à partir du moment où ces
imams en quoi c'est une maman cool c'est
franchement elle me comprend et puis
elle fait en sorte que ça se passe alors
on va voir la bande-annonce de leader
twist et juste après on s'intéressera à
jean-claude il sera minuit et demi a
tout de suite
[Musique]
merci nicolas nicolas lacombe et
musicale
c'est actuellement à la femme d'avant
soirée jusqu'à début janvier on tourne à
partir d'autres car j'ai mis 10 aces et
bravo à toi tu as beaucoup de talent on
se prend un gros bisou merci beaucoup
jean claude jean claude est avec nous
ont regardés le jean claude il est beau
il est frais il est pur on dirait un
yaourt et ouais sur le gaz naturel à
votre avis quelle est la particularité
de jean-claude à 66 ans et du karaté
oui les karatékas nom vient du ciel la
salle de sport il ya une dynamique et
ouais c'est agace tant à dire quand même
là des enfants qui nous regardaient même
sens que ça va vous êtes très chaud pour
pdif essais j'ai dit d'accord me fait
chier voulait un nom mais est donc vous
prendrez oui vous êtes vous êtes body
builder soixante six ans alors je vous
le dis alors on peu loin sur le port
tiff avant tout votre sportif avant tout
coach cotonou ressorti culié exactement
est ce que vous avez à vous voyez nord
pour y apprendre à lire et ben haim ans
on peut voir torse nu ou pas jean claude
bon c'est vrai c'est comme ça quand on a
un corps comme ça généralement quand on
te dit on peut le voir torse nu je fais
bien sûr quand un corps de merde comme
moi tu fais moi je suis pas chaud parce
que là tu vois pas tout de suite mais
bon des manouches puis ça par contre au
niveau coucou je préfère maintenant à
faire un break puis de 20 ans maintenant
vous avez fait des compétitions vous
avez des titres ou pas ouais là les
quelques anciens bains france europe
monde non ouais et non mais sans l
accord magnifique naturel 66 ans quand
vous n'avez jamais rien pris jamais
c'est bon les proches ou pas franchement
à les protéger des protéines explique et
protéger ses bons pas ces trucs-là itruc
en poudre la manger des protéines bien
sûr les trucs en poudre la whey c'est
bon ça ça fait rien si les apports
supplémentaires pour des gens qui le
voit suffisamment de protéines dans leur
alimentation normale
vous avez vous levé vous lever combien
j'ai levé mais je lève plus c'est vrai
c'est un petit peu mais je lève de moins
en moins
jean-claude juste nos téléspectateurs
c'est quoi de bodybuilding parce que moi
est-ce que j'ai une question à vous
poser plein d ailleurs à ce qu'on m'a
raconté un truc sur les body builder on
m'a dit que pour les compétitions il
mettait du nutella sur leur corps pour
que ça brille encore plus c'est que ça
faisait ressortir les muscles eux c'est
vrai je vais pas du tlm
non cela nous avait dit parce que moi
j'en mets et est une lutte à la frère
sur ma vie et je hais tout le monde
croit que je suis père monde fr ca par
contre j'ai des abeilles sur wat toute
l'année jours sur la place mon frère il
ya des abeilles qui viennent au stade
aux dauphins vous mettez d'hommes et
vous mettez quoi pas des trucs bronze
c'est un truc spécial et petit truc qui
fait c'est un mot qui fait bronzer
puisqu'il ya des projets qui nous rend
tous blancs donc pour faire voir les
musiques qu'on est obligé de mai du
thanh ha ouais même les blacks qui
seront loire voiture et mes du town
d'accord abîmée du town pour encore
accentuer le de la lumière ça efface les
parisiens très bien alors moi et on
espère vous demander un service
jean-claude pour terminer cette émission
parce que c'est la fin de l'émission je
vais tout de suite allé rejoindre
camille combal pour ils en pensent quoi
camille vous inquiétez pas on va en
continuant à 35 heures d'émission ma
gueule vous allez la voir vous le dis
donc on va on va les rejoindre camille
puisque je vais aller le rejoindre dans
un autre studio dans l'instant
jean-claude j'aimerais qu'on se fasse
juste tous les deux qu'on voit un petit
peu la personne qu'on termine au petit
strip tease
enfin vous et moi je regarde non moi
l'eau est-ce que vous voir balyo pas le
bas le bac je m'en fous je ne mange pas
de ce pain-là
ouais
super et on voit demain moi demain et
claude alexis à une émission voyant ça
le mardi et le jeudi bien sûr sur radio
voyant ce point fr il est avec nous de
marbre et technique oui non si vous
voulez voir le bar champion en belgique
aux championnats du monde le 26 en
belgique à dinan à dinant en belgique le
26 le 20 novembre de 26 pour voir le bar
pour l'instant on va juste voir le haut
[Musique]
médecin
non mais vous allez voir le beau gosse
[Applaudissements]
ouais aulas
oui
à
sans déconner on dirait que le bac il a
été dessiné ce sont vraiment et c'est
bon merci michel
j'y vais merci à tous on retrouve petit
des capitaux malgré le bon choix
jean-françois d'ailleurs qu'à venir là
bas juste le temps de le rejoindre
tudiants salue les séries
[Applaudissements]
je tousse
en direct sur scénic regardez on a les
images on est en plein coeur des 35
heures de baba et il est là
entre nous rejoindre il a changé de
pouliot pour rejoindre motivé e et le
plateau de touche pas à mon poste soit
les bienvenus
merci de toute cette journée incroyable
qui peut avec vous c'est que sur cette
chaîne de toute façon le public est là
c'est beau c'est noir telle est innocent
vous a préparé ce soir ça rien à voir
avec une enfance famille que vous suivez
chaque soir pour forcer il en pense quoi
cali est le ba ba les amis et louis
on va faire une énorme pompe est
l'enfance avant tout au long de la
soirée
y'a plein de chroniqueurs qui vont nous
rejoindre allez si lille pour salah
souci réponse à la sauce aller
[Applaudissements]
sheila si vous nous rejoignez ce n'est
pas la carte aux trésors sur temps froid
et pas qu'un peu présence aussi lille
qui est en train d'arriver dans trente
secondes à peine puis vint faire son
entrée dans nos studios les amours d'un
bourgeois il va arriver là
et appréciez vous présenter tous les
chroniqueurs qui seront faits avec nous
ce soir l'émission ça va être un grand
n'importe quoi
va pas c'est être en l'équipant micro le
public sont comme des dingues et les 35
heures vont continuer
suite
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
m
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
à nous d'être là mais ralala je suis
ravie je suis content je pense à toi
les chameaux camille frérot hyacinthe
carvalho direct
[Musique]
on va retenir comme ça 35 heures grâce à
mouiller
quand
ce passer plein de choses c'est mon cas
nick a touché ray sur cette émission
aura deux jours de suite jeudi
est ce que pendant un ingénieur du son
qui te rattrape et ont surtout merci
bravo merci merci voyez et il va
également dans les cas avant d'essaimer
voilà merci messieurs merci là c'est
beaucoup
est ce qu'on peut avoir une bouteille
d'eau également et une omelette
norvégienne on a moins au chocolat qu'il
répare on a fait de beaux duels et
cadeaux quelque chose
j'ai demandé à la régie d'enlever mon
retour dans l'oreillette sinon je vais
venir en quarts il meurt péter la gueule
même l'énervé pas ne me l'énerver béchir
bon on a plein de choses à faire je me
levais loriette parce que voilà il se
presse de satire dans la vienne en
attendant c'est dégueulasse donc je sais
je sais qu'on a partagé beaucoup de
choses pour moi mais là c'est
dégueulasse a fait un peu trop mais mais
je t'aime mon chéri alors cette émission
je vous le dis je ne sais pas du tout ce
qui est dans kaïm a juste dit il va y
avoir des défis on va s'affronter tous
les deux on paye quoiqu'il valoir huit
personnes qui vont arriver c'est ça 8
chroniqueurs de l'émission elle en pense
quoi qu'à me donne de tpm paie ensuite
on fera un grand championnat
et jeu direct avec nous parce que donc
il y aura une grande compétition on aura
les huit chroniqueurs qui seront là donc
moi ce que je pense c'est qu'on va faire
un petit chou fleur pour choisir nos
chroniqueurs des meilleurs est ce qu'on
peut appeler les personnes qui vont
participer à cette émission on peut les
faire entrer voulez mais alex
[Applaudissements]
le coeur
nous saurons plus
dans les salaires
ça va être serré merci les chats je suis
je suis toi marmonne de présenter et
mosson avec mon camion est ce que c'est
vraiment mon bébé la mère
bon ami il y aura différents que les
preuves chez vous chez vous vous pouvez
voter
d'ores et déjà sur twitter et sur
facebook pour dire à votre avis quelle
équipe va gagner très simple hashtag
team baba ou hashtag team camille et
parmi les bonnes réponses
ce qu'ont bien parier sur la bonne
équipe de ravaudage une très belle ou
beau voyage et gagner examen voyage
c'est un séjour d'une tablette ou les
soupes du balajo conrad ouellon un
voyage en tablette à la route
attention pour démarrer on va faire
comme à l'école chou-fleur d'accord
autour des marais voilà il pouvoir qui
ont choisi en premier c'est important
cyril pour les règles on a droit aux
demies je ne suis pas d'accord
quoi alors samuel roy pas faire les deux
me botter on va faire qu'on peut pas les
intentions c'est parti chou fleur chou
fleur chou fleur chou fleur chou fleur
en fleur
el fassi choisis ton premier m'envoie
des clips qui mettra donc son petit
foulard
moi je propose que pour le premier on
reçoit nice une fille ont choisi dit on
veut dans son équipe je serais donné que
tu bouges vous l'avez compris alors et
vraiment je vais choisir celui qui a la
niaque je sais pas ce que tu vas prendre
je vais évidemment prendre benjamin
castaldi
combien
c'est les 35 heures on va 35 heures de
garde et là excusez moi si je peux me
permettre au régime vous en fait
beaucoup quand même
non mais il ya beaucoup de musique
beaucoup d'élus mais ne venez pas tout
tout de suite ya 35 heures à faire
légalement un et je suis très déçu parce
que tu sais que je t'aime beaucoup et
benjamin qui veut des sushis
on dirait vraiment à sushiman là alors
je vais choisir celui
[Applaudissements]
celui qui est mon plus fidèle ami depuis
des années et des années
il y en a il y en a plusieurs ici mais
il y en a un je sais qu'il a la niaque
je sais qu'il est très bon dans toutes
les disciplines corporelle c'est jean
michel maire fait partie des petites
choses étoiles
battus cotation a tenté lui bat à
soirans choshi mal à côté de mes
camarades
calista toi je propose qu'on choisisse
une fille donc où stéphanie ou capucines
ou cette magnifique demoiselle sandra
bien sandra oh oui la houle bien donc
une fille ou bien fabien le coup je vais
pas je vais prendre celle qui
m'accompagne chaque soir dans les
enfants soient camille je vais prendre
ce type avec 20 g
alors on a les wings et david asper de
stéphanie as tu es fou match eric j en
vois tout de suite quelqu'un chez
moulinex de progresser ça m'agace un
appareil à raclette ça me ferait plaisir
à d'accord ça d'oracle est on dit
souvent que j'ai la même odeur qu'elle
est-ce que tu lises l'espace d'un bokolo
super d'accord on peut le changer
d'équipement tu m'aides rapprochant
cette équipe ou pas là dans mon équipe
fait cela en fit je vais prendre ce
calme est ce que j les considérer comme
une fille ou non il est considéré comme
en mai figue mi raisin boîte à vapeur
d'accord vient donc moi je vais prendre
et je vais prendre centrasite où je vole
je veux capucines dans mon équipe en
fait non pas trop fait moi je prends cap
haussier en jeu pour égaliser mais bien
parce que tu étais pas même de son
émission ces éléments c'est quand même
de son égoïsme et bien le 3 rouzilhac
c'est ce procès suscite bien capucine
sénégal alors sandra
son nom ça va je t'adore mais j'ai pris
d'abord parce que quand je n'ai pas
prise
j'ai jamais vu une fille qui était aussi
déçu que je vois comme ça c'est vrai non
mais vraiment je les fuis j'avais
l'impression que le monde sait qu'un
match il m'a trompée quoi un mari trompé
mais non mais attention on lave son
linge sale en famille dégagé alors là il
reste à 4 personnes 4 personnes
alors s'il te plaît si tu pouvais
prendre verde ça m'arrange je vais faire
un choix un peu surprise a pas forcément
partir sur le physique tout ça mais
comme je connais les épreuves et que ça
commence par une tournante au ping pong
amis chine est très bon dans tu joues
avec son nez
mais jean michel est déjà pris je prouve
fabien lecoeuvre bien local pour ceux
qui nous redonne fadeur à la mi longue
date et et fabien pour les jeunes et
moins jeunes qui nous regardent ne vous
inquiétez pas oui il a des boules de
pétanque dans le sud
de saverne problème à ce niveau là et
alors et alors si tu es d'accord alors
moi je vais prendre je vous lis je sais
qu'il a très envie d'être avec moi
gilles gilles jeu parce que je veux pas
prendre tout de suite pour pas
déstabilisé d'accord je vais prendre
julien parce que
soit bon
mais mardi les eaux
e le mètre les mecs juste deux mois les
gars on peut mener à passe partout de
retourner sur fort boyard
c'est renaud mais j'ai un cadeau après
cadeau de renault c'est quoi revoir pour
camille non amie camille âgés plus ils
vendent renault non amis elle s'est
vraiment halal au liban c'est le vrai il
n'a pas dit qui a arrêté l'alcool c'est
le vrai de renault non mais vous savez
je suis fan de renaud
oui vous savez que je n'écoutais que
renault quand j'étais jeune je vous jure
que c'est vrai je seul sa fille de lui
je connais toutes ses chansons par coeur
on est vraiment ab je suis d'accord
je là dans mes bras michel ça fait une
paye que c'est pas vu traîner dans mary
elle que tu vois ça va bien comme cela
ça la connaît pas c'est vrai quoi les
remercier au nom au cerf-volant et
renault pour leur lotus sera toujours
livré sur et vous toujours la banane
de boer j'ai mal aux guiboles on m'a
volé ma chignole jeu-là d'or si fous de
ce gars alors à vous de choisir mon cas
me reste un candidat pour chaque
personne yahoo un candidat ces deux
personnes que j'aime beaucoup aussi
alors moi j'adore sandra alessandra et
gilou d'abord si on l'a vu il anime à
dégager n'est pas là pour enfiler des
perles wayne est un surtout y voilà et
puis j'ai déjà pris fabien lecoeuvre je
peux pas prendre et gilles et fabien et
répartir un peu c'est là que j'allais
prendre sandra
avoir décuplé garde voilà les équipes
sont faibles en ce moment comme dans koh
lanta les rouges sont plus on attend
avec la danse la réunification alors les
shérifs giuly en régie vous pouvez
tester mon oreillette on est en direct
donc on se dit tous voulaient me parler
pour voir si l'oreillette marche si vous
voulez qu'on lance quelque chose on est
là merci et basse
bonjour syrie alors c'est bien parce que
dans l'oreillette moralisateur veut
parler comme si le gars voulaient
l'avoir disent tu sois toi même état se
voit que la remercie il commença par un
déchet et camille comme c'est toi qui
gère tu va raconter le premier jeu et tu
vas dire alors donc est-ce qu'il va y
avoir des points à chaque fois il y aura
une équipe gagnante à la fin c'est très
simple on va s'affronter sur l'un des
preuves qu'on gagnera des preuves
exactement on en a prévu énormément on
verra tout simple qu'on a le temps de
faire vous encore pendants n'adopte pas
jusqu'à plus soif
d'accord et à chaque épreuve l'équipe
gagnante marque un point les le truc
qu'ils héros point parier simca mi-août
imbaba et si vous pariez bien très beau
cadeau pour vous en fin d'émission et on
va commencer
bon ami qu'elle est quel est le premier
jeu une épreuve collective cyril alors
tout est mal joué ça va faire plaisir à
jean michel et fabien lecoeuvre
exactement puisque c'est une tournante
première épreuve
oui
alors merci aux équipes qui de soldats
sont en direct la tournante
la tendance c'est très simple les
chinois tournante c'est très simple donc
il ya une table de ping pong
on va jouer donc en tournant autour de
la cad donc il faut laisser un petit peu
de passer chez reed et ses jeux le faire
merci en art atone et en direct
donc à chaque fois vous mettrez chacun
l'un derrière l'autre
vous jouez et vous tournez il en restera
deux à la fin et donc il y aura une
finale en un point et le gagnant fera
gagner son équipe d'accord et tous les
jeunes de stocker les geôles avec man et
venait une bonne et votre hackett chacun
allait d'argent on est parti il à jean
mi voilà c'est une raquette au plus bas
merci eh bien je l'offre à quelqu'un du
public
merci aux nues alors je l'offre merci je
l'offre à saisir regardez c'est le fils
de kad merad et d'andre agassi
alors l'autre ça alors attention genre
grèce le temps le printemps est simple
dès qu'une balle est dans le si l'essor
de la table voilà on est éliminé on
quittait attention je le dis si vous
nous rejoignez je le dis pour fabien
lequel on n'a pas le droit de sortir des
balles de son slip
attention on l'aurait su
merci
on a perdu on a perdu stéphanie loire
attention les rouges contre les autres
pour le première fois c'est beaucoup
on a perdu jean-michel mais attention
pas de l'automne à potable si on perd on
joue dans le calme et chez les amis avec
le hasard il peut y avoir un rouge
contre en rouge ça veut dire qu'on peut
céder 1 c'est normal ça suffit comme ça
voilà c'est ce qui arriva qui est
derrière moi les gars pourquoi tout le
monde était contre moi là excusez moi
juste vous oui vous êtes attendus mais
sur une île mais ces gardiens loi accord
serait pas me sert fort pour moi
nick witney houston opère capucines à la
opère cap ici la nage attention alors là
ça nous sert des abattements des quatre
maisons monsieur atteint les limites et
là dans la dre obtenant dernière ma
fille allait attention elle revient
doucement et là même où un pas du tout
ça deux allez julien alecka mairie
castelle ville va vous bien joué je sais
qu
on va parler basket on a perdu parce que
attention aux loana justin a minute deux
minutes fabien est ce que tu arrives à
voir la table se rappelle je rappelle
que si vous nous rejoignez c'est un ils
en pensent quoi 14h02
oui mais quel calme toi quand même c'est
un énorme françois camille très spéciale
nous sommes dans les 35 heures voilà les
35 heures de direct
on va se retrouver dans touche pas en
toi bien sûr dans un instant pour
l'instant on est dans une épreuve
les jaunes contrôler les rouches
l'équipe de camille donc et donc
l'équipe est rouge vous mais moi je suis
l'équipe jaune d'ailleurs on aurait dû
mettre nos petits trucs qui soulignent
les médecins pour 1000 mètres après soit
la table on est dans tournante pour
l'instant il reste 2 2 jaunes pour
quatre rouges d'accord attention c'est
parti
attention il ne peut en rester cap à
l'est
[Applaudissements]
on a perdu madame à ces tensions
raciales en reste là ça chante ça
l'année benjamin on a perdu benjamin
matters attention c'est parti
attention chiffon mal et gilles il me
fait peur c'est les services lifté lohan
ou d'un boulot
on a perdu son âme
[Applaudissements]
bah ouais
attention c'est parti je suis contre mon
faible il rappelle qu'en plus ce qu'il
ya quelqu'un et lui il a quand même deux
poids de 4 kg de sandres aller à la
halle au scénario p allez on y va pas de
pouce non non pas de pouce bien sûr il a
rejoué
fabien le cadre et des mines est
malheureusement bien le joueur faire
attention et bien les gars
encouragements
c'est l'offre qui claude merci éliminé
merci c'est donc quoi qu'il arrive
l'équipe jaune qui gagnent la première
épreuve voilà merci gilles bravo gilles
voyer et quand je vois ça et quand vous
voyez ça chez vous si vous nous suivez
depuis le début de l'émission
vous devez vous devez vous dire il a
bien fait de choisir gilles en premier
leur ce niveau non mais c'est vrai merci
d'en premier point son look voyages ou
équivalent vous avez au delà de marée
vous avez bien démarré donc on a un
point pour l'équipe jaune vous comptiez
bruit continue à voter un sur facebook
et sur twitter
khamis le hashtag l'axé où tim k bis si
vous pensez qu'on va remonter tout va
bien se passer on va gagner sinon tu
imbaba si vous pensez que c'est l'équipe
de cyril gagnants parmi les bonnes
réponses
un beau gagnant qui partira qu'un beau
cadeau si la polémique alors déjà il y à
un point à 0 pour l'équipe jaune
important je sais que benjamin castaldi
alors bon on vous connaît vous êtes un
compétiteur hors pair la ceci vous êtes
très énervé à la je n'en sais rien non
mais franchement en tête vps perdent
vous détestez pas non plus une balle ou
bâle pour email pour y installer
et on n'a pas dit notre dernier mot en
la salle tout de suite la deuxième
épreuve les cherry et camille vous allez
nous expliquer comment va se dérouler
cette épreuve elle est très sain savez
une épreuve d'adressent cette fois ci
une nouvelle fois c'est collective tous
les rouges contre tous les jeunes c'est
l'épreuve des poux balle d'une gueule
judiciaire
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
alors je crois que chaque équipe
chaque équipe va avoir une minute pour
jouer une minute chacun on se met en
file indienne comme ça est ce qu'on est
de votre équipe commence que mon équipe
comment un seul mot n'a commencé qu'avec
mal puisque vous avez perdu la première
épreuve et plus en plus comme ça vous
allez pouvoir expliquer regardez bien il
faut en droit une minute pour faire des
boulettes de papier rouge et les mettre
dans les poubelles ici présents sachez
bien sûr que la poubelle qui compte le
plus de points c'est la fleur à 5.5
moins trois points au bout d'une minute
ça me plaît au bout d'une minute on
arrête tout et on voit combien vous avez
comptable dans des plans et ensuite ce
sera l'équipe jaune et c'est chacun son
tour ça je tire europe
je repars derrière et chacun son tour
anti un petit bloc et on ne veut pas
éliminer quelqu'un d'une équipe à chaque
fois qu'on roule hausse les éliminations
bon alors il voudrait se séparer de
perdre l attention attention minute par
et camille il est 17 heures 44 on est en
direct camille on y va mon chéri
multilom chrono c'est parti c'est parti
tom cruise est un mur
[Applaudissements]
d
vous avez vu
aller très bien non
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
oh les gars les gars
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
oh
hu
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
à
non
nuls cave
[Applaudissements]
corps
faire
[Applaudissements]
on va caméra s'il vous plaît venez une
caméra sous peine caméras une caméra
souplet pour qu'on voit leurs prouesses
merci les chéris eh bien on a donc trois
points
on a donc trois points +1 point et
galles quatre points en une minute
qatar
merci là bas je vais demander à mon
équipe de noirs de vouloir se mettre
derrière moi on a quatre points bas de
l'échelle en ligne il faut c'est pas
évident évident mais attention c'est pas
évident attention attention et n'importe
quoi les points là attention c'est parti
4.1 battre une minute camille tube de le
départ attention
[Applaudissements]
comprendre
c'est moi
chacun
no way
[Applaudissements]
ouais
soit non
[Applaudissements]
ouais
[Musique]
en somme
mais ces messieurs
alors vous l'avez il y avait quatre
points à battre mais on a deux ah ouais
hu car ça c'est non non non voilà
c'est gagné deuxième point pour l'équipe
de bataille et la tribune a three joue
pas beaucoup mais non mais non non non
non je suis là c'est parce qu'ils ont
poussé la table de la salle à voir non
je vais vous dire
c'est peu
si vous nous rejoignez nous rejoignez
nous sommes dans ils en pensent quoi
camille va masquer une émission de type
e spéciale aujourd'hui pour les 35
heures d'antenne qu'on va faire en
direct
ils viennent de dire que la table et a
été poussé je ne vois pas pourquoi vous
dites ça voyez bien que cette table
n'est pas pensable le voyez bien voilà
donc non je ne suis pas d'accord et je
voulais dire que tout ce papier
bien entendu on va le réutiliser non
mais c'est vrai non mais c'est vrai les
chéris baisse que ça c'est du papier
chaîne pas le gâchis des couleurs sans
rien qu'à millions d'amis dont pour
l'instant ils en pensent quoi camille et
baba eh bien il ya 2 0 pour nous pour
l'instant je veux régler pour les vins
qua non nulle pas l'épreuve elle est
validée on va être un peu plus vigilant
ici sa revanche je rappelle ken que
c'est vers l'est ce qui fait gagner deux
épreuves il accalmie trois points vers
des dégâts mais contestable
si je peux me permettre à l'elysée que
nous avons chéri merci d'être là en tout
cas merci je peux me permettre je vous
le dit gilles verdez a encore eu du pif
sur les deux épaules vraiment bravo mon
ami donc pour l'instant il y à 2.0
j'espère que vous allez vais avoir pas
mal d'épreuves pour vous rattraper parce
que pour l'instant c'est pas facile il
épreuves auxquelles on s'est affronté
cet été cyril wecht j'ai eu la chance de
gagner s'appelle la pétanque molle et
c'est l'épreuve
l'épreuve suivante c'est maintenant et
ce qui est bien c'est que c'est encore
une collégiale c'est tout les rouges
face à tous les jeunes et c'est
maintenant c'est de la pétanque mais
avec des boules molles
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
merci à on est quand même la seule la
seule chaîne où il ya quand même un gars
très bien être et du très beau
s'aperçoit donc voilà tout ce qui amène
quand même des boules de pétanque sur un
plateau c'est l'arrestation d'autres
démissionnaires
merci en tout cas
donc comme vous pouvez le voir donc il y
a huit boules by bull et malheureusement
nous sommes dix exactement millions
personnes de l'équipe deux jours à peine
alors tu vas donc désigner quelqu'un qui
n'a pas joué dans ton équipe dans mon
équipe
et malheureusement c'est stéphanie qui
ne fera pas ce soir sur l'adresse
écoutez d'un village de pétanque la
boule et peut-être d'un village de
pétanque et bien retourner bras
forcément je ne vais pas enlever les
deux personnes âgées donc jean michel
maire et gilbert mais voilà julien
pasquet comment il se sent la pétanque
très bien maïga bien et elle m'a gauche
vous c'est juste très très bien la
pétanque
ah oui oui alaska puis si on peut faire
un chiffon me si vous voulez alors si
vous voulez je peux faire quelque chose
c'est que je ne peux ne pas faire cette
épreuve et vous laisser jouer tous les
cas la sissili jouer mais cinéma parce
que vous parlez vous n'êtes pas du tout
dans mon équipe on a quand même savoir
ce qui se passe on vous personne qui
n'est pas du tout dans mon métier c'est
comme si vous avez un psg om et
régionales à jouarre de l'homme qui vais
peut-être pourquoi ils ont pas fait
choisir at-il fait le jouet
metella qui veut lui je regardais j'aime
écrire cette personne déjà déjà je ne
vous avais pas reconnu je ne savais pas
ce que vous faisiez la rue alors j'ai
bien parce que si on perd ça est de ma
faute
alors moi je vais aller jouer tous les
quatre et je vous coacher y aller
d'accord je mets tous mes espoirs dans
ce groupe
d'accord ne me décevez pas tu as
forcément sinon il y aura des gens au
chômage dans les chéris je vous fais
confiance alors comment ça se passe
comme ils ont chacun une boule c'est
très simple d'accord à chaque partie on
éliminera les deux boules les plus
éloignés à toute personne qui n'entache
pas on jette le cochonnet
on joue tout simplement à la pétanque
normal sauf qu'on blesse personne c'est
de la pétanque molle
les deux boules les plus éloignés du
cochonnet ce seront les deux éliminés ça
peut être deux rouges beaucoup de jaune
d'un coup peu importe d'accord à la fin
alors qu'il en restera là comme nice
vous êtes placé ici attention vous
mettez là bas alors allez-y premiers
chèques en bois allez-y oui les
châtaignes cédé 2 me bauland son merci
en tout cas vous vous n'êtes pas très
fun
ça lui parle en mon attention camille il
n'y a pas de marques au sol je trouve
que c'est un peu la même heure sera ici
niveau du pupitre
non non là là là celle-là c'est là c'est
la voilà c'est là le rôle de faire un
petit peu à peu près attention cabirou
démarche fin très mais vraiment ça on a
un an personne ne s'entraîne avec
jacques ans excusez moi je savais qu'on
fait une émission j'ai des chiffres qui
tombent tous les quarts d'heure c'est
cruel mais on y va elle est molle elle
est molle alors mal pas mal
attention j'ai quelque chose à vous dire
si la boule touche n'importe quoi elle
est énormément rire immédiatement la
boule sera prise sera menée directement
au rectorat de paris
la creg minutes il a le il a le geste
[Applaudissements]
rattachement
je savais je savais en disant que je
m'étais capucines dans l'équipe je
savais que je faisais une bêtise le
plaisir de la voir passer avant la
victoire c'est quand même la seule
personne qui joue aux boules
on dirait qu'elle valait quand même bien
tu roules on dirait cavale en voiture
c'est pas prêt ni les mollahs ne
déconcentrait pas l'adversaire elle
pousse est la mienne aussi un homme et
la femme tous été à un pouce pas deux
ans rapaces ça passe pour l'instant il
ya 2000 je sais pour l'instant c'est
capucine qui est éliminé il ya deux
boules qui s'excentre bravo
amal a bien joué ça julien pas ce qu'est
mon ami et
pour l'instant on perd encore parce
qu'il a et b opère et appuyer nos pertes
de jaune bravo moi j'arrive à jouer
veine les séries la messe est dite pour
l'instant aux pertes de jaune on perd
capucine et julien pasquet julien vous
êtes plus loin ça dégage les plombs un
camion voilà donc et en plus vous êtes
de mon équipe donc ces deux boules
dégage là je propose qu'on élimine trois
personnes sur le prochain os qui est
parce que sinon on fera les 35 heures je
suis cette époque attention camille pour
look et vous reprenez bien entendu on
change on change au cochonnet de pascin
c'est normal c'est la loi bien vous on
va l'éloigner un peu plus en plus dire
attention c'est parti pointe là elle est
belle
hormis seule mère est partie de l'équipe
jaune à bâle est juste deux minutes
parce que mon frère et ami ya quand même
une personne qui fait des commentaires
depuis tout à l'heure qui ne sais pas du
tout qui est qui dans l'émission vers
des si les deux jours ça c'est sa
mission
ça fait quand même
jean-michel merde ça fait quand même
vous le connaissez sur décarie 80 effet
l'émission il est allé ni jean michel
maire il avait saison aujourd'hui dans
l' il en a qu'il en a 62 voilà donc
merci ok ok c'est des conneries merci il
ya une tension car pas mal c'est pas là
c'est par al jazeera castaldi qui est
avec camille combal aïda dommage c'est
pas mal et non ça sera
penser ça a touché sa touche et infi a
touché un fil et flore et est touché
attention à bien donne tout elle est
belle elle est belle il me pose pas la
jouer
et
ça passe les deux éliminés sont les deux
guides qui avait une grise mois castard
à jama castaldi et et non mais je vais
le retrouver un chez moi et basse et
vous mais c'est pas lui le gill and on
and on and broc et bien derrière merci
on a perdu jean michel emeyriat donc
plus que gilles verdez non il n'a 3 1 à
3 et la fois éliminé il ya celle c'est
aussi assez sommaire effet moitié t elle
si c'est vous et bien c'est réglé on a
un prix mais moi je suis bien d'avoir
une réflexion de capucine haddad qui dit
il y avoue encore la capucine à l'afp
qui a rien compris je ne jouais pas
sandra à la télé il ya des caméras farce
et voilà camille en tout cas pour
l'instant vous revenir au score
puisqu'il ya deux points à 1
la pétanque molle donc c'était là c'est
en fait la quatrième épreuve vous l'avez
pas son troisième filet ou en or voilà
dans un stade bayard des trucs de dingue
qu'on va faire un curling humain
c'est-à-dire que chaque personne en
choisira une personne cyril et on devra
la poussée on va tout installé et on
devra être le plus près de la cible en
poussant un chroniqueur sur une chaise
d'accord pour cette étoile pour cette
épreuve
je fais appel à gérard louvin c'est mon
joker
est ce que c'est possible
brasilia il ya deux points 5
on va jouer donc au curling humain alors
qu'amy donc voilà il ya les cibles là
bas il ya des points exactement ça va se
passer
on devra pousser chacun notre tour un
nos chroniqueurs et être le plus près
possible de la cible ce sera toi face à
moi est un des 2 marquera pas
d'appliquer d'accord très simple ensuite
on aura des bols des énormes gaulle
avait quelques sons culture générale
dans chaque question des trucs un peu
des yeux et il vantera tirer des
questions seraient général capucines
on se reparle tout à l'heure vous voulez
rester mais juste avant vous le savez
pendant ses trente cinq d'ailleurs on
vous fait gagner beaucoup de cadeaux
vous savez il y a vingt mille euros de
cadeaux il ya des séjours pour vous
pouvez gagner un séjour d'une semaine au
soleil à quatre personnes
voilà parce que on vous envoie pas seul
au soleil il ya des chaînes
voilà où il vous dit vous avez gagné un
voyage vous y aller seul et on viendrait
si vous avez des amis
eh bien non avec deux amis directement
avec quatre personnes grâce à bel ombre
à saisons d'une valeur de 2000 euros et
la question la voici
ça parle du grand camille combal
quelqu'un combal bien sûr vous
connaissez son job 1892 1912
camille combal dans quelle station
station pas de métro à la station de ski
et merde j'ai donné la réponse la
question
alors il ya une autre question on me dit
parce qu'en fait la question c'était
dans quelle station camille combal at il
grandit qu'une station de ski huppée
station de métro du fomc s'est passé
donc à une autre question qui est encore
plus plus difficile
quel est le surnom qu'on me donne
régulièrement un baba de thatta cet
ensemble
il ya donc 20 mille autres cadeaux à
gagner nous envoyer baba par sms au 7 38
38 vous appelez le 39 27 les chinois va
se retrouver dans un instant pour le
curling humain c'est un ils en pensent
quoi camille très spécial il en pense
quoi qu'alibaba puisque nous sommes dans
les 35 heures les shirin va atteindre là
ça y est on a quatre heures antenne de
4000 euros pour l'association c'est
faire du bonheur cqp d'enfants malades
qui font un travail fabuleux et c'est
l'association que parraine omar sy
l'essai on va démarrer dans l'instant on
va se mettre en place on aura chacun
notre premier candidat
donc on doit pousser ces personnes qui
vous doit être le plus proche du centre
de la cible c'est sa femme camille on
les enlève à chaque fois on peut les
pousser
on l'est on les poussons les adhérents
les vins pas d'accord je croyais qu'ils
restent émoi toute leur vie adacore sont
des potes sont allés redresser vers des
activités
ils font des trucs à côté des faibles
bien sûr en tout cas vous vous avez un
avantage parce que ça fabien lecoeuvre
c'est le seul qui n'aura pas je vais
lever les jambes
[Rires]
on se retrouve dans quelques secondes
5 heures elle est ouverte aux tarifs